bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ses horaires des france parlez
nous de la situation là-bas en guyane
oui bonjour donc effectivement ivan loi
pour par le maillot récente et guyane
mais la situation c'est une situation
catastrophique assez dur vives pour pour
les guyanais nous sommes quand même à
5700 cas confirmés 146 cas nouveau
depuis les 20 dernières 24 heures et 26
personnes en réanimation en guyane et 12
personnes et passe année c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui en termes de lits de
réanimation en a une capacité à peu près
une trentaine de lits et on gère le
stock on va dire un combat en envoyant
des personnes en évacuation sanitaire
soit en martinique soit en boîte sont en
guadeloupe etc en sac pour nous c'est
une situation on va dire un aveu d'échec
de l'état dans cette gestion là
puisqu'on entend dire que tout va bien
le nécessaire est fait la ministre de
l'outre-mer l'ancien est venue il ya
quinze jours et il ya quinze jours nous
avait promis un passage à 46 45 lits de
réanimation plus 60 et aujourd'hui on
apprend que les forces armées vont
mettre en oeuvre vingt-deux personnes
pour ouvrir quatre lits de plus donc
aujourd'hui c'est une situation
catastrophique tout en sachant que ça
fait 20 ans que la guyane réclament des
moyens supplémentaires en termes
sanitaires et gestion de la santé ça
fait 20 ans que réclame à chu qu'on n'a
jamais eu qu'à jamais été utile et que
là aujourd'hui on n'est toujours pas
d'actualité
et pour de la crise de 2017
on s'est aussi battu pour pouvoir payer
des fournisseurs en évoquant pour
pouvoir payer des fournisseurs faire
vivre l'hôpital et ajouter une vingtaine
de lits supplémentaires en chirurgie
aujourd'hui l'offre de soins du
territoire est insuffisante
donc imaginez aujourd'hui avec une crise
sanitaire tels que le coc ville 19 et
surtout quand on se sent en fait pas
pris en compte et pas géré de la même
façon que dans l'hexagone
parce que dans l'hexagone quant à
mayenne on va tester trois cent mille
personnes
aujourd'hui le nombre de tests réalisés
sur ce territoire
à ce jour est d'à peine 25 25 mille
tests pour une population de 350
personnes
à peu près des renforts sanitaires qui
arrivent peu à peu à ce que vous avez
des informations là-dessus
bien sûr les renforts sanitaires depuis
les deux semaines où on a réussi à les
obtenir alors ça fait deux mois qu'on
les réclames abbas et 20 personnes par
semaine 20 personnes par semaine et donc
du coup comment voulez vous gérer une
crise sans précédent 5700 cas pour une
population de 300 milles c'est ça nulle
part ailleurs on est même au dessus
aujourd'hui en termes de par habitant je
parviens par habitant d'impact de la
crise on est au dessus aujourd'hui delà
de la chine en est au dessus de l'italie
et pourtant on n'a pas les moyens en
adéquation donc vingt personnes arrivent
par semaine alors qu'il faut en fait
aujourd'hui il manque à peu près 300 à
400 professionnels soignants en guyane
300 à 400 alors le voilà le premier
ministre castex arrive en guyane
elle est peut-être déjà arrivé justement
il entend rappeler la mobilisation de
l'état dans ce département d'outre-mer
qu'est ce que vous attendez du premier
ministre le premier ministre est
sincèrement madame en matant rien du
tout parce que il vient son territoire
8h15 il va faire très exactement 8h15
sur le territoire il va passer il paraît
un moment convivial avec nos élus alors
que nous sommes en crise sanitaire et
qu'il y a des gens qui meurent en a 23
décès en même pas aujourd'hui à moi donc
aujourd'hui on n'entend rien de spécial
parce qu'on a vu une ministre de
l'outre-mer qui nous a promis des lits
de réanimation et à ce jour l'ouverture
de lits supplémentaires quinze jours
après n'est toujours pas fait donc on se
demande qu'est ce qui se passe en fait
qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi
aujourd'hui on est incapable de donner
les moyens à ce territoire de combattre
cette crise sanitaire
donc il va venir il va aller apparemment
regarder en termes de distribution
alimentaire ce qui ce fait il va aller
valider les moyens financiers qu'ont
apportés l'état au niveau de la santé
très bien mais aujourd'hui ce que nous
voulons c'est des moyens de ceux de
sauver les guyanais des moyens pour
soigner les malades
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui meurent
chez eux faute de lits de réanimation et
de lits
spitz alisation sur les 23 décès la
plupart des personnes ne sont pas passés
par la case réanimation parce qu'on n'a
pas les moyens aujourd'hui de les mettre
sans réanimation soit en hospitalisation
et qu'on laisse les gens chez eux et les
autorités locales
dans quel état d'esprit sont tels quels
rôles jouent ces autorités locales ma
nous sortons justement actuellement
d'une réunion avec les grands élus de
guyane où une motion a été signée notion
de revendications pour vous dire a été
signée par les élus les grands élus de
guyane et les différents collectifs de
la société civile et je voulais un point
un point tout simplement l'air
renforcement des équipes soignantes
qu'ovide or réanimation est en
réanimation
on en est toujours à réclamer les mêmes
choses qu'on réclame depuis deux mois
donc si l'état doit enfin à s'occuper de
ce territoire il faudrait que ça soit
vite et il faudrait que ce soit en
moyens conséquents
vingt personnes qui arrivent par semaine
sur ce territoire ce n'est pas suffisant
pour hélico enrayer la crise
merci à vous ivins degois porte-parole
du collectif mayouri santé guyane merci
à vous